[Music]
let's talk about sausage party it's the
first CGI animated r-rated film ever you
guys are our man you're we're breaking
ground we're like the Jackie Robinson of
filthy disgusting animated to see the
worst sentence ever thank you
why don't you explain sausage party to
the game well sausage party is like when
you if you go to a supermarket and you
leave what you don't realize is that all
the food and everything in the
supermarket comes to life and has a life
of its own and so this movie explores
what that life is like for all the food
in a supermarket okay and you don't play
food I don't play a food Conan I I play
a a feminine hygiene product that's sold
in the supermarket is sold in the
supermarket I play a douche
I am a
how did you find the voice of this
character oh well it was a tough one
originally it was like a British villain
and then it changed and they were like
it needs to be more like a douche and I
was like come at me bro
that works so we just locked into that
like something it just came naturally it
was yeah it was there to be had now we
have an exclusive clip yes an exclusive
clip that has not been seen this is
exclusive anything we need to know about
this I think the setup is that I am
believe that I'm leaving the supermarket
but being purchased and going to fulfill
my douche destiny and something it's
derailed by a sausage and a bun very
nice the sausage is Seth Rogen and the
bun is Kristen Wiig man Hollywood keeps
cranking out the same old stories
alright this clip from sausage party did
you do this to me are you to responsible
for my nozzle being it were possibly
easy man easy yeah your nozzles been
sorry but you know what you should be
happy you're alive yeah bananas hole
face peeled off peanut butters wife is
dead look at him he's right there
you think I give about P P or J yes I'm
gonna kick your ass
are you like dem ah ah no not you come
at me balls fine you won't come at me
that guess who's coming at you
[Music]
you're only gonna get douche roles from
now on you know that you'll be typecast
fingers groves
all right sausage party is in theaters
August 12th oh hello which is hilarious
on Broadway debuts at the Lyceum Theatre
on September 23rd Nick Kroll you're a
good man too stop
you